did you know that Sylvester Stallone was
brought to court by the same man the
rocky franchise was based on and can you
guess which famous billionaire Tony
Stark is inspired by these are 10
characters you didn't know were based on
real people
Ronald Weasley is one of Harry Potter's
best friends without Ron's great sense
of humor and loyalty Harry would be so
lost anything off the troll it is no
thanks
almost set but we may not have even had
Harry Potter if it weren't for the
person Ron was based on JK Rowling based
Ron off her childhood friend Sean Harris
who especially meant a lot to her
because he was the first person with
whom I really discussed my serious
ambition to be a writer and he was the
only person who thought I was bound to
be a success at it certain real-life
details like Sean's Ford Anglia also
made it into the books oh and for those
of you who were wondering Hermione is
inspired by a younger version of Rowling
herself while Harry is based on JK
Rowling's childhood friend and neighbor
Ian Potter a boy who actually shares the
same last name as Harry although using
childhood friends as her models worked
in Rowling's case what can you do when
you're trying to write a personality
that's a little well bigger that's right
turn to celebrities how can you put Tony
Stark into words genius billionaire
playboy philanthropist thank you Tony
when Stan Lee and his team first created
Iron Man for the comics there was only
one man they were thinking of American
billionaire Howard Hughes Stan described
him as one of the most colorful men of
our time but when it came time for Tony
to be reinvented for the MCU they had
someone a little more modern in mind the
writers modeled their version off of
Elon Musk in fact Robert Downey Jr even
sat down to talk with musk because he
felt this is the guy who can give us
some insight into what it'd really be
like to be Tony Stark the inspiration
runs so deep that musk even received a
cameo in Iron Man 2. Mr Musk
thank you congratulations to the
promotion but celebrities aren't the
only one ones who can Inspire characters
Larger than Life
the code name for the secret agent James
Bond was based off of will give you a
hint he wasn't 007 and whether or not he
liked his martinis shaken or stirred is
well still up for debate instead meet
Forrest yo Thomas codename White Rabbit
a secret agent for the British forces
during World War II who served around
the same time Ian Fleming got the idea
to write a spy novel there's also
paperwork to connect the two of them and
plenty of yo Thomas's real life
experiences resemble something out of a
Bond movie so even though Fleming
claimed there were many men who inspired
007 this guy was as close to being a
real life Bond as you should be to
subscribing by now go on click it anyway
there was this one time when yo Thomas
found himself trapped on a train
surrounded by enemies in a moment that
comes straight out of From Russia with
Love and the writers for Casino Royale
even took a bit of the inspiration from
Yo Thomas's grueling capture by the
Gestapo for a few scenes and speaking of
characters who had to work Undercover
have you ever had one of those teachers
you'll just never forget that was John
nettleship for JK Rowling he was a
chemistry teacher who taught her during
her time at secondary school and with
his long hair short temper and gloomy
laboratory he became the perfect
inspiration for Severus Snape when it
came time for her to write the Harry
Potter books apparently his own students
were the first to point out the
similarities to poor John and as he put
it I was horrified when I first found
out I knew I was a strict teacher but I
didn't think I was that bad as time went
on however Jon would eventually come
around to the idea cementing himself
even further into the World of Harry
Potter by writing books and giving talks
on the way that the local area had
inspired Rowling's work at least it
seems that everyone remained on friendly
terms in this case it might be a good
idea to get someone's permission before
you go telling their life story Chuck
wepner was a new jersey-born boxer who
fought under the moniker of the Bayonne
bleeder he came from a tough background
and was considered a bit of an unknown
figure in 1975 when he fought boxing
Legend Muhammad Ali wepner lost but he
still managed to withstand 15 brutal
rounds and even knocked Ali out at one
point now all of this may be starting to
sound familiar to you at this point a
young Sylvester Stallone watched this
1975 fight on TV and shortly thereafter
began work on his script for the movie
Rocky using wepner as his inspiration
when wepner eventually saw the film he
said that's my life up on that screen he
took my life and made a movie of it
wepner eventually filed a 15 million
dollar lawsuit against alone in 2003
which was settled out of court at least
Chuck has to be happier with the way
that he was able to inspire the
imagination than our next guy here you
kinda have to feel bad for the guy that
this character was based on you probably
know Jabba the Hutt as the big gross
slug guy from Star Wars who took
Princess Leia captive and had Han Solo
encase stick in carbonite but what you
may not know is that George Lucas had a
bit of a tendency to take inspiration
from his own childhood when he was
designing his creatures and when it came
to putting together Jabba the Hutt he
asked his production team to make sure
that he was alien and grotesque like the
actor Sydney Green Street this helped
the design team get their creative ideas
going and at one point they'd even come
up with the idea of having Jabba the
Hutt where a fez hat exactly like the
one Green Street wore in Casablanca it's
funny how the costume an actor wears in
one movie can inspire a whole other
character in that way sometimes
inspiration can come from the strangest
of places when actress Arlene Sorkin
handed her College buddy pauldini a tape
of herself as a clown from Days of Our
Lives she probably just expected him to
laugh at it but seeing as Paul was
riding for Batman the Animated Series at
the time this tape actually gave him an
idea he'd already been trying to work
out an idea for a female sidekick to the
Joker and when he saw this let's do what
they do on the castle down the block
will throw the peasants in the boat and
watch him drown everything just sort of
fell into place Arlene even got to
provide the voice for her and she didn't
put a whole lot of time into preparation
that's right the high nasal brooklyn-ish
Cadence that everyone's been copying as
the original Harley voice is really just
Arlene sorkin's natural speaking voice
fight being turned into a clown may not
seem like the most flattering portrayal
but at least it's better than our next
one he's obsessed with getting pictures
of Spider-Man and holds a lot of control
over public opinion but are we talking
about Jay Jonah Jameson or Stan Lee
Spider-Man with his hand in a cookie jar
whoever brings me that photo gets a job
you probably don't think of Marvel's
lovable old figurehead when you look at
the cranky editor-in-chief at The Daily
Bugle even if there are a few slight
similarities like say their age and
their mustache but all that's just
surface level right well as it turns out
when Stan Lee was asked if he'd based
Jamison's appearance on himself he said
you caught me I really did in fact when
Stan created Jameson he just thought to
himself if I were a grumpy irritable man
which I am sometimes how would I act and
that was it we're just hoping that Stan
was an easier boss to work for than
Jameson what are you looking for a raise
get out and hey we love that Stan didn't
take himself too seriously kinda like
our next entry on this one list it's
hard to pin down the right inspiration
for a sea witch you can't just base the
character on a family member as in our
next entry it has to be the right person
writer Howard Ashman was brought on to
work on The Little Mermaid during a time
when they were still struggling to pin
down a look for Ursula nothing seemed
right that is until Ashman suggested
that they base their design on the drag
performer Divine you see Ashman was a
huge fan of divine and as a fellow gay
man from Baltimore he felt he could
understand both his way of seeing the
world and his sense of humor you can see
Divine in Ursula's exaggerated makeup
cheek mole and white Mohawk but the
similarities don't end there Ashman
continued to write Ursula with Divine
sense of humor and he even coached Pat
Carroll to sing with divine's
distinctive growl how would you feel
growing up alongside your famous
fictional counterpart Christopher Robin
became a world famous name for his
adventures through the Hundred Acre Wood
alongside the Winnie the Pooh and
Friends written by author A.A Milne
Milne had actually based Christopher
Robin on his own son who was also named
Christopher Robin Winnie the Pooh was
based on a friendly black bear at the
London Zoo that Christopher loved so
much he eventually named his teddy bear
after him Christopher's other stuffed
animals inspired other characters like
Tigger and piglet at first Christopher
loved these stories because they made
him feel Grand and important it wasn't
until he began to face bullying at
boarding school that he began to develop
a love-hate relationship with his
fictional namesake that has continued to
this day Christopher found that he began
to dislike his father's stories more and
more as he grew older but didn't know if
his father was ever aware of this
you may not know these people's names
but we'll certainly never forget their
stories were you most surprised to find
out was based on someone real and are
there any other examples we might have
missed we love a good story here so make
sure to tell us down in the comment
section